Throughout human history humanity has sought to create a virtuous city or an ideal society.
The American dream was based on a kind of utopia.
Why do we have a shaker movement? Why do we have Quakers? Why do we have so many different
I am a religious movement that left Europe in search of a Utopia in America?
Well we know that the Shakers have disappeared and many of these entities have disappeared
They can only be found in margins in US textbooks, and the question is why?
One of the most important reasons is scarcity, because the industrial revolution was at the beginning of its inception
Communities have scarcity, scarcity causes conflict, and conflict is eliminated.
This entity will collapse and disintegrate. How do you distribute resources? Who will have access to food when there is not enough?
Who gets shelter when there is a snowstorm if you ate the little corn? These challenges faced Americans in entities
This is why we only see the ruins of these utopias
In any case, today we have nanotechnology, and with nanotechnology who knows, perhaps in the next 100 years we will have what is known as:
In Replication Module: It is the same thing in the Star Trek series and its atomic name
It takes normal raw materials and begins to destroy them and even reconstruct them at the atomic level in different ways to form new materials.
If you have those molecular motors you can use them, for example: to turn the glass into wood or vice versa, you will have power
Similar to the power possessed by the magician, in real power resembles the power of God.
Strength in the ability to convert atoms of one material literally to another and this is what we saw in the series Star Turk.
These discoveries may be the most effective method, if Utopia failed due to scarcity, deficiency and scarcity of materials
So what happens when you have infinite abundance?
What happens when the application comes to you simply?
One of my favorite episodes of Star Trek's series is Facing the Space Capsule of the 20th Century Remnants
The bad twentieth century when some people died because of terrible diseases, some have frozen themselves because they know that in the twenty-third century
Sethopone and their diseases will be treated. Well, as expected, this is the twenty-third century now and the capsule has been found and begin to treat
All these people have cancer, as well as their treatment of certain hereditary genetic diseases
In any case, one of these individuals, a banker was revived and he speaks with himself and says:
I am alive; I am in the twenty-third century. Then he said: Contact the broker of my financial papers .. Contact the banker I am rich I am rich
My investment has been dormant in banks for centuries I am supposed to become Quadrillionaire
And then the project crew looks at this man and says to him: What money? What is the bank? What is a banker? We do not have these in the 23rd century
And then they say to him: If you want something, ask him simply to get it ..
Now this destroys our concepts and this is a revolutionary change
Because Utopia has failed because of scarcity and shortages of materials, conflict and conflict. What happens when scarcity disappears and when you ask and simply get what you want?
This will have great philosophical consequences.
For example, why does it cost people the trouble of working? Why is he interested in going to work when he asks for things he simply gets?
Some sociologists believe today that if restrictions on drug use are completely lifted, for example
Maybe three to five percent of the human race will become addicted.
This is the price of the results of deregulation and the overall legislation of drugs. I'm not sure about that number for sure, but the figure they talked about.
But what will happen when we have this community based on replicas?
So can we have 3 to 5% of parasitic humans?
All this is contained and is of course based on the human human soul based on the production of things to do something special or to contribute or participate in it
What happens if you do not have to do these things?
And what happens when you have infinite abundance? What happens if there is indeed a virtuous city?
That the critics will say - this nonsense!
No Analog Copier This adapter violates the laws of physics?
Well, actually this is not true.
In fact, nanoparticles are being multiplied by disassembling their molecules and restructuring them in new and fascinating ways
The nature created by Baal is believed to be called the ribosome
The ribosome can take hamburgers and milk and turn it into a nine-month-old baby.
This is a miracle. The ribosome takes hamburgers, french fries, and potato chips, disassembles them and recombines them into DNA
Our natural safety has a replication unit
It reproduces the human ??
But what happens if a person can produce a molecular reagent? To copy everything? This is really a revolutionary idea
Translation: The Arab team in the Zeitgeist movement